[Applaudissements]
merci ça fout les jetons vrai bien sûr
je pensais pas pouvoir rentrer à paris
dauphine par le prisme d'un ted
j'ai l'impression c'est vrai même
beaucoup plus dure qu'il est prof de top
chef alors à l'évidence quand ils sont
venus me voir avec à l'évidence
moi je me suis dit mais à l'évidence il
faut être créatif je voyais pas d'autre
chemin je voyais pas d'autre
d'autres raisons d'autres réponses qu'il
fallait être créatif dans la vie alors à
l'évidence la création c'est important
parce que ça fait au moins deux ou trois
mille ans que tout le monde parle de
création
alors je me suis dit réfléchi il faut
qu' il faut que tu t'y mets alors je me
suis dit la cuisine ça me passionne la
création ça me passionne
je vais être un chef créatif manque de
chance en france y sont nombreux ils
sont tous très connu ils sont tous très
étoilé
donc comment quelqu'un qui n'était
fils de ou élèves de coûts qui a pu
faire une haie grande hôtelière une
grande école hôtelière puisse prétendre
à exister dans ce monde assez élitiste
de la gastronomie
alors j'ai fait comme tous les chefs
tous les cuisiniers
j'ai étudié j'ai étudié la cuisine
classique escoffier legrand escoffier la
légende escoffier est alors en étudiant
explique l'officier en étudiant meba
vrillant la cuisine classique
je ne reconnais pas tous évidemment mais
j'ai retenu une phrase une seule et
unique petite phrase la cuisine sans
cesser d'être un art devra soumettre ses
formules trop souvent empirique à la
science ouah alors je peux vous dire que
quand la cuisine la gastronomie
moléculaire est arrivé dans les années
90 est 2000 je me suis dit c'est pour
moi je vais leur en sauna et donc je me
suis dit je vais écrire mon propre livre
de cuisine
je vais écrire mes propres recettes
en m'appuyant sur mes propres cahiers pc
et j'ai fait naître planète marx cuisine
structures et des structures la tomate
cubique leçon
si san virtuel la tomate iceberg
le sorbet aux fruits rouges en
cryoconcentration la magie la tarte au
chocolat translucide
c'était génial le livre sort petit
succès de librairie mais quand même
fort de cela chaque seiler et ont créé
le cefic le centre français d'innovation
culinaire qu'elle gastronomie pour 2050
avec raphaël haumont créé ce centre on
grandit on devient une chaire
universitaire formidable de 2004 2005 on
passe à 2006 chef de l'année chef de
l'année
et puis chef de l'année élu par la
profession j'ai été élue je n'aurai pas
été choisi donc on m'a élu chef de
l'année deux fois étoiles michelin
espoirs 3 étoiles jury top chef
cinq années et cinq années et
et puis aujourd'hui on me paye pour être
créatif on me paye pour voir cette
gastronomie 2050 on me paye pour ouvrir
des concepts de restauration et ça de
façon planétaire j'ai envie bien
bon on a bien rigolé oui cette cuisine
je les pensais je la voulais absolue je
la voulais avec de la quintessence je la
voulais esthétique
je la voulais avec une vision un impact
social environnemental
je voulais que cette cuisine donne de la
mémoire et de l'éphémère
je vous ai tout dit ça c'est le
storytelling ces scellés dans les revues
star et il a fait ça il a 60 balais
quand même oui bah oui il a fait tout ça
oui j'ai fait mais ça c'est le le côté
de la médaille qui est en lumière
maintenant je vais vous raconter la
vérité c'est pas
tout pareil ça a été entre quinze et
vingt années d'un chemin assez tortueux
entre l'ordre et le désordre créé c'est
dur créer c'est difficile il ya une
phrase de cho-power que j'aime beaucoup
dit dans toute création dans toute
innovation vous serez d'abord moqué
ensuite vous serez violemment critiqué
et ensuite on dira c'était évident
moquer petite histoire ça a commencé
très tôt dans ma carrière j'étais
apprenti pâtissier
j'avais un gâteau à faire ce qu'on
appelle dans mon métier à gâteau c'est
un entremets aimé aider mes anciens me
disent il faut qu'ils nous fassent un
joli c'est une pièce de concours il faut
faire quelque chose de très beau jeu
fait un gâteau et je m'inspire ta grands
pâtissiers du xviiie antonin carême je
fais une jolie cloche en sucre
et puis le gâteau en dessous je pose ça
sur la table de mes aînés il ya un
ancien qui me dit mais le gâteau une
très beau magnifique
il prend le décor il enlève le décor et
il me dit mais on n'est pas des
décorateurs d'intérieur parlons
pâtisserie parlons métier alors avant
d'innover apprend et bâle une autre
anecdote
quand le livre planète marque sort je me
souviens de cet écrivain est ce ce grand
critique gastronomique était christian
millau quand ils voient planète mars il
dit faut siffler la fin de la récréation
c'est pas sérieux tout ça
or que lui il avait apporté en france la
nouvelle cuisine
et puis les amis et proches
les pères qui vous disent mais des sur
vraiment envie de jouer à l'apprenti
chimiste
ça c'est des gens qui ont peur pour vous
ils savent que ça va faire mal
snav que ça va être douloureux donc ils
ont peur ils sont inquiets ils sont
inquiets de votre propre échec
et puis très rapidement
arrive la critique brutale violente dur
je me souviens un mensuel très connu en
france
thierry marx le fossoyeur de la
gastronomie française
sympathique mon premier restaurant à
paris
n'y allez pas c'est ridicule un grand
quotidien
et puis un autre
quotidien qui titre ouais bon il ya
quelques nouveautés mais il n'y a pas de
quoi se relever pour un resto de soja ou
pour une tomate cubi que d'autres y
avait peut-être déjà pensé
là on vous regarde hisse tout de suite
alors je repense à ce que je viens de
vous dire de schopenhauer
quand il dit vous serez moquez vous
serez violemment critiqué probablement
vous serez ringardisé assez vite et
c'est pas le pire
c'est pas le pire parce que dans
grande solitude dans la grande solitude
du créateur
il ya quelque chose qu'on oublie souvent
c'est le doute
le doute qui vous ronge qui vous ronge
de l'intérieur qui vous fait avoir peur
de vous même et si j'étais resté un bon
suiveurs et si j'étais resté dans la
zone de confort j'aurais pas tous ces
problèmes
et puis le doute se durcit s'approfondit
et s'il avait raison
si je n'étais qu'un pitre
si je n'étais qu'un prétentieux qui est
envie de faire parler de lui tout
simplement quelqu'un suffisamment
mercantile pour faire de l'argent avec
du buzz donc vous doutez peut-être
qu'ils ont raison vu que 99 % de mes
essais je les met à la poubelle
là
sion c'est l'école du deuil il faut le
savoir et c'est normal c'est normal
qu'on voit hills c'est normal quand vos
critiques
vous êtes en train de faire bouger des
cercles des cercles établi par d'autres
peut-être plus compétents que vous vous
faites bouger des rigidités des
certitudes vous déranger
donc c'est dur donc la déprime vous
guette
par moments c'est dur de faire bouger
tout ça c'est dur de déranger c'est dur
d'être le moustique qui empêchent des
géants de dormir
ce traitement difficile
j'étais foutu les jetons
bon alors j'espère que je vous ai pas
tous donné envie d'être comptable d'être
des suiveurs malhabile dans soyez
créatifs et et des projets ne soyez pas
suiveurs alors dans le projet dans la
création il ya l'idée que je voudrais
partager avec vous il ya quelques
conseils à mon âge peut peut-être me
permettre de donner quelques conseils
comme je le ferais pour mes enfants
comme je ferai pour mes proches comme je
ferai pour mes apprentis comme je ferai
pour mes amis
si vous créez pour être célèbre vous
allez échoué
j'en suis convaincu si vous créez pour
être riche
créée pour être un rebelle
on ne crée
ces raisons
vous échouerez mais si vous créez pour
les autres pour améliorer la vie des
autres au service des autres je suis
absolument convaincu que vous ferez
partie de ces grands créateurs merci
[Applaudissements]